uh but for me my only association with
that plant was i i didn't like eating it
because i was a kid i didn't like those
tastes
um it was an opportunity for me to spend
time with my grandmother because um
my sister would go off to school when i
was really little and my grandmother and
i we would just go down to the creek
and i would throw rocks at snakes that
was honestly what i would do stephen can
i just ask you a little bit i mean you
are in a pretty special position as an
actor and being able to work in the us
with tv series like you know the walking
dead and also in south korea with films
like octa and
burning and so going forward
where do you see yourself and is it
difficult to balance the demands of two
industries in two different countries
both of which want you
um
uh i hope both want me um i don't know
yet uh i've just been kind of really
been going case by case if i'm if i'm to
be honest um
you know i
after i was fortunate enough to be on um
walking dead
um
i didn't really go to seek out
film in korea
or projects in korea um i was really
just trying to focus here
and um
the one thing that i got to touch when i
first did okja
uh that kind of sent me on a different
path was
um
i guess uh a truer reflection of the
place that i inhabited as as kind of
just an immigrant
kid
um
uh you know working in that movie as
that character k who is caught between
two worlds and in some ways unable to
service either of them effectively i
think um kind of mirrored a reality for
me where i was where i was kind of
allowed to see
myself a little bit clearer and then um
for burning or uh
you know then be nutty to come along it
kind of just feels like a season
um
uh i i don't know it feels very
fortuitous to be quite honest with you
burning came out of nowhere um to be
able to work with such as incredible
director
uh like
is is you know a dream and so um that
one i just said yes to you know i was a
yes of course um and then you know with
isaac you know reading his script and
and knowing his talent like just
i i guess that's that's all i'm really
in search for as an actor is things
where i can feel a little
bit fuller
that i can participate in a way where i
can participate as a human and maybe not
as like sometimes
a construct or an idea
and so
wherever any of those projects are um i
think those will probably be where i
gravitate towards um whether it be in
america or korea or anywhere um but i
will say um speaking in korean
um
it's it's it's a lot more work
for me
so
um you know maybe maybe i'll uh keep it
to english for a little bit but um or
i'll just keep improving um but you know
it's um
it's just
i don't know i i i don't know where i'm
headed i'm just kind of uh
riding this ride right now to be quite
honest i'm i'm very thankful for this
ride
i'm going to just ask something going
back to the the sort of maybe not the
writing process but the the title of the
film obviously it's um taken from a
plant um
but obviously there is some significance
to it and it has a symbolism and so i
just wondered could you explain a little
bit about you know what does it mean in
korean culture in cuisine
and what's the symbolic element that it
brings to to the film
um
you know to be honest i didn't know much
about minardi other than what it meant
for my own personal family growing up in
arkansas i just knew that it was a plant
that grew really well
at this creek where my grandmother
planted it
and my parents would always talk about
how healthy it is and how good it is for
you
but for me my only association with that
plant was i i didn't like eating it
because i was a kid i didn't like those
tastes
um it was an opportunity for me to spend
time with my grandmother because um
my sister would go off to school when i
was really little and my grandmother and
i we would just go down to the creek
and i would throw rocks at snakes that
was honestly what i would do and she
would pick this plant and uh and we
would just talk and joke together
so there's an association with that
plant for me that's purely emotional
but as i was researching the plant later
as i was writing the script you know i
learned that
the plant itself it's
very robust it grows
in the first season it it's something
you try to let die and then you harvest
it in the second uh season and the
second growing of it and somehow that
encapsulates the immigrant experience
for many of us
um and and it it tends to make the water
around it very clean it gets planted in
very dirty conditions but it it purifies
what wherever it is
um
so just
you know learning those things it just
felt like um icing on top that
those are really the poetic resonances
of the plant itself
um so can you talk a bit about you know
the choice of working with the
cinematographer like from milne um and
how you worked with him to create this
this look
yeah uh lachlan milne is one of my
favorite people on this work earth uh
he's a superhero to me
um
we we had such little time to do this
film uh on production and um a lot of
the look is really um him working
intuitively and and uh shaping the
lighting and
finding the right angles that we need
um while letting me focus a lot on the
actors
um but but something that we talked a
lot about as we were uh deciding to look
and figuring out you know where to put
the camera and all those things
we we uh we didn't want it to be
completely realist where it's just like
documentary style or anything like that
but we wanted a feeling of a fable a
feeling of a tale
um
and so
there's a slight
we talked about creating a slight staged
element to it as well
but letting that feel like a
a very natural
sort of stage where where everything
looks naturally lit and
striking that balance i i just gotta say
that
i i
i
give my hats off to lockheed it's almost
like everything that i
wanted and hoped for like he understood
internally and knew and knew how to make
happen
so the very first shot that we did was
um
[Music]
steven comes in with the money after
buying the tractor and puts it in the
dresser
and then they have kind of that that
moment of a failed kiss
um
and i was so stressed about this
production and how are we going to
deliver and as soon as i saw the way
that lockheed set up the lighting and
everything
uh i'd say half of the burden that i was
feeling just felt like it was lifting
like oh i found my partner here this is
my partner um and and from then on out
it was our first time working together
um i mean i i trusted him completely and
and
um it was a joy to to work with him he's
he's a great dp
[Music]
[Music]
you